[Music]
it's a tough business you meet a lot of
different types consistently everybody
says the same thing about you such a
nice guy and we know I know a lot of
your friends I know people that have
worked with you everyone has said it
from day one since you got into this
business
steve carell nice guy do you ever feel
like you're that's a burden to be known
of as one of the nicest guys in the
business yes I am not that nice a guy
I'm sort of I'm a middle in sort of nice
mid-range nice I'm not a complete prick
don't know if I can say it you can't and
now this won't air no no I know you're
not you're you're you you so you think
you're I know I'm not no I'm not
especially nice yeah Tom Hanks makes me
look like an
yeah well he's crazy nice but I think
you're up in that I really do think of
you oh he's got that image it's I
wouldn't say it's a burden but there are
there are times that you kind of wish
that people thought you had a little
more grit you know a little more but I
look like the guy in the mustache yeah
yeah you know do you do you think do you
think I mean you should do something ok
you should do some act you should do
something that that resets the bar for
you that I think gives you a little bit
more of that I'm badass image I don't I
don't even know what that would be I
don't know I've never been given the
opportunity to be sort of a badass to be
a just I don't know why don't you just
break something why don't you what if
you broke something right now is
something something that
I you know just write it just this this
is a mug that I've had I've had this mug
this Eisenhower mug it was on my desk at
the citizens limits that is off-limits
because I've had that a long time that's
very precious hour they actually break
this though I do can't rate that you
can't break that
[Applause]
I don't even care
screw you and your memento mug 25 years
[Applause]
this guy I like this guy
yeah but he wouldn't like this guy cut
to after the show him behind backstage
gluing it back together yeah sorry after
the show you're gonna be crying like a
baby gluing that fact it is so glad that
that was actually the fake mug that's a
fake mug yes I prize because I and I
looked over there and I was like oh I
hope I really hope they switched it we
did switch it because I would freak out
imagine if I was like hey no--but call
us a bit trash so decked up oh yeah
well you would be devastated if such a
thing like that happened because you are
a nice person unfortunately yes yeah
there was a time actually doing this
movie it just made me think there we do
this this illusion and in Burt
Wonderstone where I we do this hangman
trick and they put the they put the
noose over my head and all of the stunt
people said if if it's too tight just
say don't don't stop stop stop stop stop
and they put the noose over my head and
I it was too tight and what stop stop
stop stop and no one heard me and they
went boom and I went through the bottom
oh really
scared the hell out of it does this
story end with you being dead
[Laughter]
so when you see the movie you'll see me
going now I want to see that